we've had so many successes it's hard
when you're looking at such an enormous
field to keep a cheery countenance
because there are so many ways I always
say we don't have the luxury of one
cruelty in one place that we can work on
it because it's an all encompassing
philosophy of all different animals used
in horrible ways in all different
pursuits but we've had many successes
for example when you see mannequins
testing cars on TV that's because of the
animal rights movement they used to use
baboons and pigs and slam them into
walls in cars Peter stopped that and it
was a lot of campaigning when you see
pleather instead of leather or synthetic
fur or you see natural fibers that's
because people said I don't want to buy
things that mean that an animal is
skinned sometimes alive for his coat so
when you see the veggie burger and the
silk in the store you can eat that and
be healthier but it's there because in
the main not only were people pushing
for it for health that because
especially young people see what is
happening on the factory farms and in
the slaughterhouses and say please give
me something else to eat I want the
convenience that a meat-eater our dairy
eater has but I don't want
you